tout de suite l'actualité de la semaine
retour en images sur les principaux
événements du département tout
musique en gare c'était dans les gares
du réseau car jaune pour la fête de la
musique
quatre rendez vous au programme
à la gare de saint benoît saint denis
saint paul ou encore saint pierre une
scène est ouverte pour permettre aux
jeunes artistes locaux de se faire
connaître
hélas aujourd'hui profité pour lancer
quelques extraits de mon nouvel album
enfin mon premier album j'aurais aimé la
scène et tous ont une gare ou une
synthèse pour moi ça vaut chose en fait
une initiative qui ravit les archives et
qui est très bien accueillie par les
voyageurs ben moi je viens d'arriver je
vois que de la musique c'est très bien
ça va attirer d'autres voyageurs
c'est l'animation c'est pour détendre
l'atmosphère voilà est mieux dans la
journée dans l'après-midi écouter un peu
de musique
l'objectif de cars jaunes et du
département les simples animer ces lieux
de passage emprunté par plus de 50 % des
usagers
samedi 18 juin à l'espace régler s'est
déroulée la restitution des activités
pédagogiques et culturelles sur la
découverte de la chine
nous avons réuni 17 classes 17 classes
qui ont travaillé toute l'année sur un
voyage en chine à travers les livres et
c'est un moment où de restitution elle
agit j'estime que c'est une très belle
initiative du conseil départemental fait
découvrir aux enfants d'où est née notre
peuple mans nous racines notre vivre
ensemble notre métissage je fais carnet
dedans il y a comme de paysage est beau
et leurs fleurs et et sur ses carnets
génie encore le dragon nous avons un
partenariat avec la bibliothèque cette
année c'était le thème de la chine
nous avons aussi travaillé à l'école des
albums sur la chine sur l'horoscope
chinois
puis nous avons eu quelques séances 6 je
crois dans l'année à la bibliothèque
départementale où là les enfants entendu
des histoires et ensuite travail sur la
fabrication dakar nettoyage sur la chine
un plateau goyaves à petit ils ont
commencé le 21 juin les travaux routiers
sur la route départementale 3 donc les
travaux consistent à faire de la
sécurisation playtone par les trottoirs
par des carrefours surélevée et de la
sécurité on va dire aussi drôle hic
c'est le troisième quartier le plus
urbanisée de la ville de la petite île
c'est un quartier qui bouge
régulièrement il y à une école il ya un
passage piéton important on se devait de
répondre à cette à ce besoin de sécurité
de sécurité piétonne près les marchés ya
de plus en plus de marcheurs je vois moi
aussi je marche tous les soirs parce que
c'est bien fois la population pour les
enfants y aura ma petite île
effectivement à cette chance d'être
l'une des premières communes premier
canton canton 22 à bénéficier de ces
investissements importants 1 million 400
mille euros dont neuf cent mille euros
porté par le département ce n'est pas
rien ce n'est que le début puisque nous
avons mis en place un programme
pluriannuel d'investissement après piton
des goyaves ce sont les travaux sur
ravine du pont ravine du conte ce sont 5
millions de travaux qui vont être
engagées dès 2017 avec une participation
du département à hauteur de 2 millions 5
l'histoire d'une esclave man est
racontée par les élèves du collège
bourbon
la ned qu'eric exhumé des archives qui
devient l'héroïne d'une pièce de théâtre
où se mêlent fiction et réalité
gêné d'abord dans le cadre du concours
sur les esclavages les traite et la
bodega puissions au delà de la
production qu'on avait proposé on a
voulu aller plus loin et proposer une
vraie pièce de théâtre mon travail ça a
été vraiment de mettre au plateau des
élèves qui avaient jamais
jamais fait de théâtre donc il a fallu
faire des exercices d'échauffement des
exercices sur la voie en plus il joue
dans des conditions qui sont pas simple
parce qu'il joue en extérieur donc dans
un lieu magnifique la bdr et décret de
la république prend la tête haute et
exécutés vous avez je vous le donne le
rôle de nanette d'amérique
c'est une esclave qui passent chez les
bons et les affranchis en 1840 quand 8
grâce à la nette les collégiens
connaissent désormais une partie de leur
histoire
j'ai été contacté par madame maçon à
partir d'un travail que j'ai fait qui
est en ligne sur les reconstitutions de
famille d'esclaves et donc la famille
delhi le révolté de saint leu leu des
responsables et détaillées sur ce site
et on trouve parmi ses soeurs une
jeune fille qui s'appelle nanette et qui
va connaître l affranchissement de 1848
madame
en allumant
son épitaphe imaginé par les collégiens
de bourbon lui redonne sa dignité d'être
humain
nanet n'aura jamais été libre de son
vivant désormais elle l'est pour
l'éternité
la fête de la musique
google utilise une décote à l'occasion
de la fête de la musique le propre style
vent noir nike propose un concert de ce
type en un instrument qu'ils ont
découvert quelques semaines auparavant
les styles panne ce sont des gros fut
découpée dans des barils de pétrole ça
vient directement le tribunal de bagues
aux eskimos qui présente la
particularité d'être a pris facilement
parce qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
connaître la musique neil solfège donc
le style panne c'est ce jour n'encaisse
il ya chacun fait quelque chose de
différent comme comme un orchestre il ya
la base c'est de l'accompagnement la
mélodie et les percussions tout ça donc
ils ont monté un orchestre en 13 séances
ils ont heureusement ce projet mené en
faveur du public de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance associe les enfants et leurs
familles autour de la musique dans ce
quartier où beaucoup de familles vivent
dans l'isolément plusieurs jeunes dotés
de prédisposition naturelle pour la
musique ont été repérés et invités à
participer à ce projet elle va dire
plusieurs notes du coup j'aime bien
jouer ce on a quand même des assistantes
sociales on a
les éducateurs on a une équipe directive
qui a pour mission de travailler pour
les enfants pour la famille et faire en
sorte que on leur fasse découvrir aussi
des choses qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
connaître et puis en même temps de
renforcer le lien familial